Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say'!
Do you know what to say when you need to deal with a problem?
Listen out for useful language for dealing with a problem.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Yuna!
Oh, morning!
I've got a bit of a problem.
What's wrong?
Can we talk in private?
Of course.
Right, so, what's the matter?
Well,
I've made a mistake.
A big mistake.
OK.
I'm sure we can work it out.
It was such a silly thing to do!
I'm getting worried now.
What's going on here?
OK.
It was late last night
and I was tired
I wasn't concentrating
and I
accidentally used my company credit card instead of my own to buy something!
Don't worry,
these things happen.
There's a procedure to deal with this.
How much did you spend?
It was quite expensive.
How expensive?
It was very expensive.
Vanya,
how expensive?
£3,782 …
and 56 pence.
What?
You spent £3,782?!
… and 56 pence.
What was it?
Vanya?
Just a weekend break!
I just like a really nice hotel!
OK, I see.
Thanks for letting me know.
Ah!
I feel so much better now I've told you.
Please don't tell Noelia.
Oh, I'm definitely going to tell her!
Hi!
Hello again!
Wow, that's a lot of money for a weekend break.
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for dealing with a problem?
Listen to me and then repeat.
What's wrong?
I've got a bit of a problem.
Could we talk in private?
What's the matter?
I've made a mistake.
I'm sure we can work it out.
Don't worry, these things happen.
Thanks for letting me know.
I feel so much better now I've told you.
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you need to deal with a problem in English.
Bye for now!